now Jericho was tightly shut up because
of the children of Israel no one went
out and no one came in Yahweh said to
Joshua behold I have given Jericho into
your hand with its king and the mighty
man of Valor all of your men of war
shall march around the city going around
the city only once you should do this
for six days seven priests shall bear
seven trumpets of rams horns before the
ark on the seventh day you shall march
around the city seven times and the
priests shall blow the trumpets it shall
be then when they make a long blast with
the ram's horn and when you hear the
sound of the trumpet all the people
shall shout with a great shout then the
city wall will fall down flat and the
people should go up every man straight
in front of him Joshua the son of nun
called the priests and said to them take
up the Ark of the Covenant and let seven
priests best seven trumpets of rams
horns before Yahweh's ark they said to
the people advance march around the city
and let the armed men pass on before
Yahweh's ark it was so that when Joshua
had spoken to the people the seven
priests bearing the seven trumpets of
rams horns before Yahweh advanced and
blew the trumpets and the Ark of
Yahweh's covenant followed them the
armed men went before the priests who
blew the trumpets and the ark went after
them the trumpets sounded as they went
Joshua commanded the people saying you
shall not shout no let your voice be
heard neither shall any word proceed out
of your mouth until the day I tell you
to shout
then you shall shout so he caused
Yahweh's ark to go around the city
circling it once then they came into the
camp and stayed in the camp Joshua rose
early in the morning and the priests
took up Yahweh's Ark the seven priests
bearing the seven trumpets of rams horns
in front of Yahweh's Ark went on
continually and blew the trumpets the
armed men went in front of them the rear
guard came after Yahweh's ark the
trumpets sounded as they went the second
day they marched around the city once
and returned into the camp they did this
for six days on the seventh day they
rose early at the dawning of the day and
marched around the city in the same way
seven times on this day only they
marched around the city seven times at
the seventh time when the priests blew
the trumpets Joshua said to the people
shout for Yahweh has given you the city
the city shall be devoted even it and
all that is in it to Yahweh only Rahab
the prostitute shall live she and all
who are with her in the house because
she hid the messengers that we sent but
as for you only keep yourselves from
what is devoted to destruction lest when
you have devoted it you take of the
devoted thing so you would make the camp
of Israel accursed and trouble it but
all the silver gold and vessels of
bronze and iron are whole
to Yahweh they shall come into Yahweh's
Treasury so the people shouted and the
priests blew the trumpets when the
people heard the sound of the trumpet
the people shouted without great shout
and the wall fell down flat so the
people went up into the city every man
straight in front of him and they took
the city they utterly destroyed all that
was in this city both man and woman both
young and old and ox sheep and donkey
with the edge of the sword Joshua said
to the two men who had spied out the
land going to the prostitutes house and
bring the woman and all that she has out
from there
as you swore to her the young men who
were spies went in and brought out Rahab
with her father her mother her brothers
and all that she had they also brought
all of her relatives and they set them
outside of the camp of Israel they
burned the city with fire
and all that was in it only they put the
silver the gold and the vessels of
bronze and iron into the Treasury of
Yahweh's house but Rahab the prostitute
her father's household and all that she
had Joshua saved alive she lives in the
middle of Israel to this day because she
hid the messengers whom Joshua sent to
spy out Jericho Joshua commanded them
with an oath at that time saying cursed
is the man before Yahweh who rises up
and builds this city Jericho with the
loss of his firstborn
he will lay its foundation and with the
loss of his youngest son he will set up
its gates so Yahweh was with Joshua and
his fame was in all the land
[Music]